bruce spanner and natasha romanov have a
complicated history
from that scary chase scene to that
infamous heart to heart
here are the biggest black widow and
hulk scenes in the mcu
ranked from best tourist the best scene
between natasha romanov and
bruce banner might just be their first
it comes in the avengers when natasha
has been tasked with recruiting bruce to
the team
at the time bruce is on the land living
in kolkata and working as a medical
doctor
he shows up at what he believes to be
the home of a patient but instead he
finds agent romanov waiting for him
bruce is immediately on edge and he asks
if the building is surrounded but widow
is calm
and casual assuring him that they're
alone she tells bruce that she's come to
recruit him for his scientific expertise
smiling nervously bruce muses that
perhaps she's come to lock him up which
widow denies
finally bruce slams down his fists and
shouts
stop me at this natasha becomes deadly
serious and draws a hidden gun
it's now clear that natasha has been
absolutely terrified of bruce this
entire time but was hiding it like a
champ
something further underlined by the
reveal that shield agents had the
building surrounded the entire time
it's a tense and beautifully constructed
scene that also
manages to quickly teach us everything
we need to know about these two
characters moving forward
bruce is trying to achieve balance
between his two halves and doesn't want
to be caged
natasha is excellent at hiding her
feelings and
she's far deadlier than she seems on top
of all that it's mark ruffalo's first
real scene playing banner and he totally
knocks it out of the park
another of our favorite moments between
hulk and widow comes at the end of
avengers age of ultron in a scene that's
arguably the final resolution of their
romantic subplots though we didn't
know it at the time after defeating
ultron the avengers are fleeing the
floating chunk of sokovia where they
took their stand against the killer
robot
although most of the team including
black widow escaped aboard a shield
helicarrier
the hulk opted for a different way off
the island flying away in a stolen
quinjet
as he flies further and further away
from the rest of the team
natasha pops up with a video message
with visible concern and longing on her
face
she pleads with him to turn the plane
around instead hulk terminates the
message
and sits in silence as the quinjet flies
off into the unknown
it's a beautiful little scene that we
enjoy in large part because of its
simplicity
bruce never wanted to be an avenger in
the first place and now he has a chance
to disappear forever
his only regret is that he won't get
seen that again and
all of this is clear on both of their
faces without either of them
saying a word another hulk in black
widow scene that we simply adore
comes early in age of ultron as the
avengers celebrate victory over hydra
back at stark tower
natasha is pouring some drinks behind
the bar and bruce walks up to her and
things get a little flirty it begins
with pleasant banter as bruce uses an
old movie lean to get natasha to play
along
as their flirtation continues though
natasha essentially confesses that she
has feelings for bruce and tries to get
a sense of whether or not he feels the
same way
since bruce is a huge dork though he's
less skilled at this sort of banter and
he fails to give nats the answer she's
looking for
this moment is a big shift in their
relationship when their simmering
romance officially transitions from
subtext
to text though this romantic pairing
took many audiences by surprise during
their initial viewing of this film
it's a genuinely great little
interaction the two have some real
chemistry and it's nice to see two
sombre characters having a little fun
also it's a little thing but we love the
fact that widow being a veteran super
spy
is way better at flirty role playing
than the awkward and
uptight banner all in all this scene is
a delight
when loki's forces launch a surprise
attack against the shield helicarrier in
the avengers
an explosion sends bruce and natasha
tumbling down into the aircraft's lower
decks
natasha finds her leg pinned under some
debris and bruce
overwhelmed by his stressful
surroundings starts to turn green
by the time natasha frees herself and
starts limping away bruce has become the
hulk
from there a tense chase scene ensues as
an injured widow
struggles to run and hide from a monster
that used to be her ally
this little horror interlude is a really
cool scene and it's a nice tonal
contrast with bruce and natasha's usual
flirtations
that being said we don't love the fact
that during this sequence in which
all the rest of the avengers get to do
cool stuff the lone
female member of the team is relegated
to getting injured running away from a
monster and then spending the rest of
the sequence cowering in the storage
room
before finally getting rescued by thor
after losing a few points for that
this scene is still pretty great overall
after their tearful goodbye at the end
of age of ultron
hulk in widow's romantic subplot is more
or less dropped from the series moving
forward
there is however a little nod to their
past entanglement in avengers infinity
war when the team is reassembling in
order to make a stand against thanos
after spending several years as a
fugitive when black widow finally
rejoins the team
she finds an unexpected person waiting
for her back at avengers hq
during bruce and natasha's brief
interaction it's immediately clear that
the pair still have a great deal of
affection for one another but it's also
clear that neither one is entirely sure
of where they stand or what they want
from each other
the two never get to have another big
heart to heart at least
not one that we see and they spend the
rest of the film fighting against thanos
rather than patching things up
we wish the scene could be a bit longer
and that it gave us a resolution to this
particular plot line but
infinity war is such a dense film that
we imagine the filmmakers just didn't
have time for it
that being said what we do get here is
still pretty great
so this awkwardly sweet scene stands out
among the bruce natasha moments
here's the scene we have mixed feelings
about from age of ultron natasha has
been captured by ultron and bruce
arrives to save her
he frees her from her jail cell and
tries to convince her to leave with him
but she wants to stay in fight
we cut away for a bit and see that
ultron has begun his final plan
to levitate a section of scovia up into
the sky when we return to bruce and
natasha he tries again to convince her
to leave with renewed vigor instead
natasha does
this i adore you after the kiss
she pushes him into a pit a moment later
the hulk leaps up from the abyss below
and lands in front of natasha grinning
and ready for action
this scene isn't higher on our list
because it's an example of a time when
the writers want to have it both ways
they want to show the audience that
after everything he's gone through bruce
is genuinely traumatized and he no
longer wants to be the hulk
at the same time though for the climax
of their big superhero movie
they want the good guy version of hulk
to be involved punching robots and stuff
their way of accomplishing both these
goals is to have natasha
non-consensually transform an unwilling
bruce
it's fine but it's also sort of a cheap
gotcha twist and
it's played entirely for laughs in a way
that doesn't really acknowledge that
this is a genuinely awful thing for nat
to do to bruce
who really doesn't want to be the hulk
anymore after the team breaks through
the defenses of a hydra base it's time
for the avengers to reassemble and head
home
however since the hulk is still
rampaging around in the woods natasha
sent out to calm him down
and it's here that we get to see the
first appearance of the team's new
technique for de-hulking the hulk
the lullaby hey big guy
sun's getting real low with the gentle
caress of the hulk's palm and forearm
after uttering this code phrase
natasha seems to immediately calm the
hulk down then
after a moment the big guy backs away
and collapses to the ground
transforming back into a shirtless
banner honestly we can't really decide
how we feel about this scene it's sort
of a cool idea that widow has the
ability to help calm down the hulk and
get him to transform back into banner
but the whole scene has a sort of
uncomfortable energy to it that just
doesn't work for us we're not really
sure what director joss whedon was
thinking with this one but if he was
going for
sexy he very much missed the mark it
seems like perhaps even some of the
other folks at marvel also weren't
super big fans of this somewhat awkward
scene as it was later turned into a
punchline in thor ragnarok
despite their long history black widow
and the hulk share barely
any screen time during their final film
together avengers endgame
natasha's storyline focuses much more on
her relationship with hawkeye
and bruce's time is split between
reconnecting with thor and
doing science stuff that being said the
pair do have one brief interaction
together early on in the film when
natasha
stevens got to meet bruce at a diner we
learned that the big guy has now merged
his two halves hulk
and banner into a single being banner
explains that one reason he decided to
do this was because he personally blames
himself for the team's loss to thanos
there's no flirting but natasha does
make some time to comfort bruce
and to compliment him when he worries he
might not have the expertise to figure
out time travel
well you pulled this off i remember a
time when that seemed pretty impossible
too
the scene is more of a group moment but
it's worth mentioning because believe it
or not
it's the last time we get to see hulk
and widow have a real conversation
it's a perfectly fine scene the only
reason we're ranking it so low is
because of how anticlimactic this
ends up being as the pair's last true
interaction
after a lost ultron that included an
accidental hulk rampage the team decides
to lay low at hawkeye's rural family
home
while they're there natasha decides to
make her play she asks bruce to run away
with her but he refuses saying
she's out of her mind his reasoning he
feels that being the hulk means he can't
have a normal relationship with her
and he can't have kids she responds by
telling him she can't either
and that the red room that trained her
also had her sterilized
it's efficient
one less thing to worry about perhaps
there's a version of this scene that
could have worked we'd love to see more
of widow and hulk talking about how they
both feel like monsters who don't fit in
that whole dynamic is the main reason
why they work so well as
pairing but in this specific execution
the writers tried to convey this idea in
a truly tasteless way by having both of
them lament their infertility
presumably without realizing it the
scene basically implies that people who
can't have kids are unfit to be in a
relationship
and that they're well monsters even if
it wasn't the intended message
this complete catastrophe of a scene
clearly gets the bottom spot
on our list with a bullet check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite superhero movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
[Music]